hi so yeah that is me
amina hussein 26 capricorn
finishing a phd in microbiology that is
mum
dad parental unit standard they didn't
always come with me to meet potential
spouses
this guy existed so
do you have any hobbies aside from
worship
worship is not a hobby yes no of course
duh
are you sure you want like some tea
sure he had dementor vibes but his eyes
were actually kind of
dreamy with the shoulders of a
mesopotamian warlord
our eyes meet to cross the sand juice
do you always dress like this bright
colors and everything
oh no no she's uh she's usually much
more modest and uh
and her skin is usually a lot clearer
but she's you know pre-menstrual
yeah she sweats a lot i mean but she's
very fastidious please stop have you
been on hajj not soon
uh amina why don't you play everyone a
song what
what which she's playing at the syrian
children's fundraiser
at the town hall please stop music
is haram totes in it yeah i'm not
actually playing
my kids are playing you have children no
i teach guitar to
underprivileged youth charity the kids
are playing at the fundraiser not me
i i don't perform no you don't have to
worry she hates playing in public
huh i know we disposition induces
diarrhoea and vomiting
what was that song you used to play
hey
[Music]
okay so my husband quest was going
fairly disastrously
little did i know things were about to
change
big time
[Music]
i'm gonna kill my sister
[Music]
is
lady parts that was their bad name
concocting a confused mix of hash
anthem's
sour girl power one part boredom two
parts identity crisis
stop stop why are we slopping we sound
wank
profoundly wank harsh assessment now you
know what we sound worse than wankers
what's worse than
wank emeroids you know what i think we
sound great boris johnson
no we sound [ __ ] on a cosmic level
athlete's foot puberty camo toe the play
black lung
vegan cheese shut up taz we caught a
dish of a sound smash
sounding like this you said that lost
you maybe the universe is ready for our
vibes man
no no why'd you have to be such an epic
boner kill all
the time we are not ready can't you hear
our sound is thin
we need something more we need lead
guitarist
hi ron i beg you man don't start this
again start what again
sisters man with mutual love and
admiration we
lift each other up yeah feminism in it
hmm [ __ ] la tigra babes in toyland
great three-piece bags
blink one e2 blink blink yeah bling
seriously blink okay fine
don't blink joe i think any guitarist
could be a good shot historically
four piece bands do have a higher
success rate like metallica rolling
stones beatles
we're in a punk band we don't need a
wanky
self-indulgent guitar who is just
[ __ ] all over our songs
we're getting a new guitarist just
decided
who'd have thought that our orbits were
soon to collide
like a freight train careering towards a
cute unsuspecting land
who innocently trotted onto the tracks
in search of
i don't know snacks i'm the lamb by the
way
[Music]
you